[Music]
injustice for jr. news submitted by
Mario from Fresno oh you must be an
Italian farmer five suspects are in
custody after mistakenly killing a 15
year old oh you guys heard about Junior
no what it where's it from what we're
gonna take a bronze Oh sounds like an
accident
yeah that sounds like a purposeful
killing no they accidentally killed the
wrong guy was it gang violence young
phenom
so let's lisandro Junior Guzman fellas
it was his full name he was 15 years old
the dreams of becoming a police officer
oh so he was like a super straight kid
yeah he was a great he was a good kid
apparently he did know like their
reports that he did know his attackers
but that he wasn't affiliated at all
because the attackers were gang members
how many partners grew up in the same
neighborhoods so I'm gonna show you guys
the footage that police released it's
very disturbing so if you guys don't
want to watch it skip ahead if you got a
weak gut oh please don't turn off video
or feet got a weak gut just take
pepto-bismol cause it's really sad so
this story is really sad and it touched
a lot of people it's like a lot of
celebrities wait I can't be crying up
here I want people to hit up song look
away look away okay but if you cry
people love you yeah so apparently these
gang members thought that they they were
upset over some video of this girl that
was getting as she was getting ran by
some dude and next to her we're getting
what rammed like I was getting [ __ ] by
some dude they're mad because they
wanted to have sex no apparently this
little
but apparently this girl was related to
one of the gang members and so that was
in this really quick video it was a few
seconds long so like one of the guys was
rapping and then the other dude was
[ __ ] her and so Wow my guy was having
sex and the other guy was just having a
freestyle apparently a world is yes I
didn't he was providing the music for
the romantic couple like you know when
you go on a date and someone plays on
the chord Ian but then in this case it's
like I'm a freestyle while you do the
sex that's romantic
sorry they were saying that they were
busting a train on this girl and so
that's a train I never thought I'd hear
TV so I trained I've never seen in a
porno where a guy would kill the time by
freestyling while he waits for his turn
while the other guys doing it's just
interesting then you know you would
freestyle in the middle of sex
this is who they were looking for
apparently and this is who they got
alright so now I'm going to show you
guys a video that police released from
the surveillance video so you gonna
watch it I'm some kid ran into a bodega
trying to find help and no one helped
him they dragged him out stabbed her
with the machete and he raised him he
ran to the hospital to get help from
himself no one helped him instead of
people were filming him at the hospital
he died a few steps away from the
hospital it's all like infuriating
that's so sad hit that play so he can
say it oh my god it was the wrong guy
too
oh there are all the guys yeah they're
grown-ass men oh my god they're [ __ ]
was his shank you know more points you
know there's one guy shaking them and
another guy with the machete chopping
them then he comes around he's like
trying to get help this poor kid
all my she's bleeding all over so he
just runs to the hospital that's so
[ __ ] sad heartbreak let me the store
clerk couldn't call my owner yeah no one
knows what's a man like I get so [ __ ]
sad when I see stuff like this cuz even
with that ecstasy all kid people
recorded him on snapchat you know that
even if it's a dead body like and you
don't even know if that kids dead or not
at that moment even if he was you didn't
know at that moment and the first thing
you do is you record on us on on the SS
wild so I'm not gonna record five dudes
killing somebody because it omnec yeah
like what did they keep my ulama
shouting him bleeding to death
that's wild to me dude you [ __ ] at the
hospital apparently he died a few steps
from the hospital so he was near the
hospital nurses came out they started
recording I don't know who it was just
people that knew him because they're
saying like that knew him everybody
today like you all right it's like why
bear that's [ __ ] remember why bad
it's like why bear but then like you
wanted that to happen yeah these were
people they were looking for it they did
spider-man hat - is that the machete in
his [ __ ] head the red shirt or orange
anyway maybe a couple the more some
really bright ass colors they look like
deer in there they run that neighborhood
is what that says they look like the
pitch-perfect of gangsters though you
know I mean like you know I don't
picture like what do you mean they're
looking for them opening your eyes it's
like no no this'll be found there's
other suspects luckily like really happy
about that
this is one of those times I feel like
there's like human law and then there's
like government law like for me if I had
a liquor store and I saw a kid getting
stabbed and I would probably pull out my
gun to shoot them you're allowed to
though that's that's considered
self-defense well I'm not getting
attacked no that's okay you can actually
kill someone if they're in the middle of
killing someone else or raping some oh
yes okay yeah so if I thought it's it's
it's hard to debate though because if
it's California in New York because it's
super liberal yeah but technic
we it's supposed to be okay yeah but
yeah I think like in this case my human
life is just way more important you see
this guy getting [ __ ] killed I would
just start blasting and he'd probably
like 20 shanks less him I'd only have to
fix one hole and then you could call
9-1-1 they'll get here on time and after
you save them yeah I think I think
people that live in the hood though
they're just like they know like hood
law and like they fear like the [ __ ]
gangs and and like yeah yeah so it's
like like it is [ __ ] up especially for
the people that knew him and we're like
recording that [ __ ] like though yeah
like you're not gonna get in trouble if
you [ __ ] escort him to the hospital
there yeah because that's that car but
also there's empowerment in being
ignorant to hood law so one there's hood
law right and you know okay if I shoot
at these guys these guys are gonna come
and [ __ ] me up but then there's also
like the Korean liquor store owners
during like the LA riots they're like
[ __ ] it if you're gonna [ __ ] come and
shoot me we're going to war
[ __ ] and yeah all my other
homies we're all gonna have guns well
that was like direct war with each other
right cuz it's like my life versus yours
this guy at the bodega owner that he's
like my life isn't even on the line
right now like why would I put my life
on the line I got my family to feed I
got my bills to pay yeah I'm just saying
that it also doesn't help when there is
hood law and governments like New York
or California yeah strip that power away
yeah maybe the liquor store owner can't
even have a [ __ ] gun yeah so they're
just helpless bent over like use your
super scheme it's up to my it's my I
don't know how you guys wrote but it's
like also to like you can't get mad of
like civilian people doing civilian [ __ ]
like I've never seen like a bunch of
hookers get mad at civilian people
calling the cops because that's what
they do so it's like you can get mad and
like a dude snitching because you're not
supposed to know you're a part of that
that culture and that lifestyle but if
you see somebody else who's just a
regular person call the cops they're
just a regular person call the cops I
never seen like hood dudes get mad at
them for that I'm not personally I'm not
gonna call the cops if you have a
machete in your hand and you are a foot
and a half away from me right after you
leave but like I mean I will but
like in that moment probably not I see
that I want to liquor store just so
things like that happen and I can press
a button and lock everyone in and mow
them down like growing up where everyone
knew like our house got jacked into you
like they broke into it and like people
knew who did it but like no one ever
told us no one ever called the cops on
those people cuz it's like that's just
that's not what you do you're not a rat
you know what I mean and I'm like what
the [ __ ] this is Wireless so the family
says that these gang members apologize
to the family and said sorry we got the
wrong one
exactly I knew it yeah they also said
that those guys were kicked out of the
gang and oh [ __ ] really it happens like
that like they got and they got respect
like that yeah
and so here let me show you guys I mean
that's honorable but and so this is a
mom and Rihanna posted this off with the
caption that says I can't stop thinking
about this poor baby boy and how his
family must feel right now I'm sincerely
praying for your healing and hashtag
justice for jr. and then cardi B posted
this but of them all that's what it was
I thought it was her family member oh
that's cuz I don't read much but I saw
the picture and I was like oh noes her
nephew hurt yeah she even so there was
this GoFundMe created and she don't she
donated eight thousand dollars and
didn't really publicize it is a sad
thing too about life like you could do
everything right and it doesn't mean
[ __ ] sometimes you know and that's like
I think that's why I like people who
live like very shelter lives because
they're so scared of thing that's gonna
happen this is also example if you could
do everything right in it doesn't matter
I'd rather move away I'd rather move
into a all-white neighborhood and get
picked on every day than to deal with
this [ __ ]
and that's another thing people don't
realize like well I don't do anything
bad but it's also like where you're at
and where you associate with you cause
you know yeah yeah because I'm actually
afraid of nice white neighborhoods
and I'm more comfortable or another not
me not not me anymore I used to be like
that but now I go back to certain part
of Sacramento I'm like using grapes the
same shop and you're like clinching your
product and shape it going back to like
like I've gone by the place I used to
kick it 24/7 right and I don't feel safe
I'm like there I'm like touching my
purse I'm like you [ __ ] savages goal
to cover like all the expenses right now
it's at two hundred thirty six thousand
five hundred eighty six dollars and
that's so crazy
she better move - yeah get out of there
imagine losing her son yeah and then
like the sister the older sister was
like interviewed and just saying like my
brother was innocent you didn't even do
anything
and then Lala visited the family with
Melo because her caption says yeah this
is what I wanted to do for our birthday
today thank you to the gram for
connecting me to this family I wanted to
offer our love and support - lysandros
juniors family his sister reached out to
me and told me he loved Melo so I asked
him not to come with me I can't imagine
this type of pain and sadness his family
is so strong and may God bless them
forever and then just because he looked
like somebody else dude that's like me
walking on the Miller Street if somebody
shooting me down because I look like Kim
jong-un or something yeah you know I
mean like what the [ __ ] I didn't do
anything but then I look up your YouTube
channel okay this guy is a degenerate
about the same that's so [ __ ] sad man
yeah but luckily they have five suspects
so suspects you did it one of them has
been charged already catch them and
shake the [ __ ] out of them and I got
kicked out of their gang but they found
some in New Jersey and apparently there
was one in the Dominican Republic
oh [ __ ] [ __ ] travel fast they should
let the mom shrink the [ __ ] out along mm
that's a good reward that's a good
revenge
[Music]